ça a pris un certain temps pour qu'on
fasse que je retombais photoshop com ah
oui si ce téléphone le 31 juillet 2010
est une date gravée dans la mémoire de
kim leclerc des eaux nier qu'ils
revenaient alors de vacances en italie
on était six heures dans l'avion à rien
faire et surtout voudrais par les agents
de bord qui se littéralement cacher
ouais non huguelet polio même goldman
qui dit on n'est pas des bétails le
garder nos efforts mais deux avions
cloués sur le tarmac pendant des heures
des passagers plongés dans le noir
privés de nourriture et de climatisation
un incident qui a mené à un rapport de
l'office des transports blâmant air
transat et forçant le dédommagement pour
les passagers lésés un incident parmi
d'autres qui a toutefois contribué à ce
nouveau règlement qui entre
partiellement en vigueur
la première portion vont était
d'informer les passagers sur leurs
droits au canada la grosse problématique
on l'a vécu ces dernières années c'est
que les gens sont pas au courant leurs
droits sont pas au courant des recours
savent pas comment aller chercher parmi
les nouvelles mesures
l'obligation pour les compagnies
aériennes d'informer les passagers de
leurs droits et leur recours
les indemnisés en cas de refus
d'embarquement leur permettent de sortir
de l'avion après trois heures sur le
tarmac et les dédommager pour des
bagages perdus ou endommagés
c'est dommage que ça avait pris seul
pour arriver à une charte pour arriver à
des lois claires
des changements qui entre en vigueur
malgré la contestation devant les
tribunaux de centaines de compagnies
aériennes qui affirment qu'elles devront
refiler la facture de ses coûts aux
clients
c'est vraiment un argument qui est là
pour faire par une analyse de
sensibilité qui était faite par l'office
des transports du canada
et puis à bon avec les coûts engendrés
par la nouvelle charte canadienne dans
son application complète ça représente 2
75 par billet vert au-dessus
air canada qui prend part au
regroupement qui conteste devant les
tribunaux la charte a refusé notre
demande d'entrevue
mais indique par courriel travailler à
finaliser les derniers détails et
prévoit donc être conformes aux
nouvelles règles